– Selma!
– Hallo, Sebastian!
– Ey, schön, dich zu sehen.
Geht’s dir gut?
– Danke, mir geht’s gut. Ich bin auf dem
Weg zu meinem Praktikum.
Und du?
– Ja, ich treff mich jetzt mit ’ner
Freundin zum Frühstück.
Ich hab keine Lust auf dieses
Kantinenessen in der Uni.
Und wie gefällt dir das Praktikum?
– Die Arbeitsbedingungen
in der Firma sind toll,
obwohl die Arbeitszeiten an manchen
Tagen ziemlich lang sind.
– Und dein Chef? Ist der nett?
– Er ist streng,
aber hilfsbereit und verständnisvoll.
Und ich find es gut, dass ich viele
verantwortungsvolle Aufgaben habe.
– Cool, das klingt super.
Ich hoffe, dass deine Kollegen
auch nett und unkompliziert sind.
– Ja, aber ich hab mit
den meisten nicht viel zu tun.
Ich arbeite nicht so viel im Team.
Das find ich ein bisschen schade,
aber wir treffen uns
jeden Mittag zum Essen.
– Na ja, es kann ja nicht gleich
am Anfang alles perfekt sein.
– Wie geht es Nico?
– Nico? Ja, du,
Nico geht's eigentlich ganz gut.
Der ist immer noch auf der Suche
nach ’nem Ausbildungsplatz.
Soll ich ihn von dir grüßen?
– Besser nicht.
– Okay.
Dann wünsch ich dir
viel Spaß auf der Arbeit!
– Danke.
– Bis bald!
– Bis bald, Sebastian!
– Ciao!